I never thought that I'd want to have a
kid you know what I mean like
I man just like it's weird to be who I
am now that I have him cuz I was just
like the most selfish self centered you
know even like crazy kid in the world
like it was insane where'd you get that
from from your from your
parents I don't know it's like I mostly
from doing drugs you know what I mean I
just everything was so
transactional that like it was like
either someone was ripping you off or
like you're ripping someone off so I
just I I feel like I acquired it over
time of like I have to have it to
survive you know where where did you
grow up Brandon so I uh my family's like
from Burbank my aunt still lives in
Burbank when we were about 13
um my dad moved to San die Diego my mom
so my mom and dad got divorced when I
was super young and my mom was like
super abusive like I don't know like
kind of like CRA like ah do you yeah
like yeah very physically abusive your
mom not your dad my mom yeah and
um I don't know and that that I just
never felt safe you know what I mean
with her cuz I had no clue what she was
going to
do like you know what I mean you just
there's no I didn't know when she'd be
mad or happy or you know and she what
was her deal mental issues or drugs or
what man it's crazy cuz she's never done
you know drugs or anything and she's not
like in a mental health facility or
anything right now
um I don't know I mean my dad it it was
like a lot of the time is there's like a
very like what you'd consider a
crazy still relationship between her and
my dad like she still is like mad about
it and I think a lot of it got taken out
on
me so it just I mean it was really hard
to grow up like you didn't I didn't know
when she was going to do something crazy
or physically violent or I remember this
one time I she would say that I couldn't
eat you know what I means like I like
you were bad you can't have food and it'
been like over a day and I had food so
like she went to sleep and I got up and
I you know crawled into the kitchen
super quietly I slid my finger across
the Seal of the thing to just get
something to eat and I popped it open
and boom she was right there and she
just like slammed it to the you know I
mean like slammed that door into me till
I just like melted to the ground
and it was just scary as [__] you know
what I mean it was like there was no
telling and uh I remember too just like
being bruised on my
body and like telling people you know me
like someone at I was at the YMCA and I
was hanging from the bars and they could
see the bruise and they're like what
happened and I'm like afraid cuz what if
they don't save me you know what I mean
like what if if I tell them but I have
to stay with her yeah so you don't you
don't say anything I tried not to you
make up a lie they brought it up to my
family and so this one time the cops
came and uh but they left
me you know what I mean the cops left
you they left me they didn't help me
they didn't take me they literally just
let me there to just and I I that was
like the day I felt so unsafe cuz I just
how old were
you so my brother you know my brother
was born there around like 9 or
10 and uh I I seriously prayed every day
that my dad would like get us and he
finally did and he moved us to San Diego
and
um I mean it was my a different there
was it was like a a light in my life
there was no more of that I still had to
go on the weekends and I think it was
like a Wednesday and every other weekend
we'd have to see our mom drive from San
Diego to
Glendale but I mean in my head too I was
like it's only the weekend you can make
it through this you can make it through
it you know what I mean you've already
made it through so much pretty soon
you'll be 18 you won't have to do that
anymore and luckily she got uh my
stepdad and it all stopped you know what
I mean for the most part oh really yeah
her behavior improved she never did
anything like that you know I mean no
vicious physical
altercations you know still a little
yelling um my godmother was just at a a
party with us for Halloween and she was
talking about like do you remember how
your mom wouldn't let you guys have
cheese or like there was so many rules
to how how we lived with her it was it
was insane but luckily the the violence
subsided once my stepdad Tim came and it
was just
like you know what I mean but the
weirdest I ever since then like when my
dad when he moved to San Diego my dad
worked he always was at work um I really
never had a lot of supervision at all um
I was like in the punk hardcore scene so
I didn't really like uh a lot of the
kids were straight edge so at first
nobody was drinking or using like we
were having fun going to punk shows um
there was a couple of times that I drank
the funny thing is the first time I
drank the cops brought me home and my
dad is sober and alcoholic synonymous
I'm I'm 39 so he must have like 30
something years you know what I mean and
it was a big deal um but he didn't get
he didn't he didn't go super hard on
me um I I got into like art and music
and clothing stuff
um I was in high school and uh there's a
band right now there's a band called aay
dying who me and the singer now have
like a partner partnership um we do a
company together but they were big and
my friend's band was big they were
called American Tragedy and I just
wanted to be the singer of the band so
bad and I'd like follow them do merch
all that stuff um with them every night
practices always hanging around and I
remember uh they never had me in the
band but I got the guitar player to
start a band with me and him and the
drummer lived at a house and um their
their cousin who they called pile for
pile of [__] he came over and brought
heroin and I tried heroin like a hit for
the first time and
uh it was like it was just that that
feeling took away of every
feeling of like not feeling safe or
secure and I don't know I kind of chased
that you know what I mean it was like
soon after we're smoking heroin every
day um we started some bands and we
would tour and we could make it like
three days but it's like I'd have to
come back you know what I mean um I
remember me and my friend Jacob we
brought the heroin dealer with us to do
merch and
everyone in the band was using so every
person thought like you're gonna you got
me right like the whole time and all of
us were using so he was like out like
day two we were in Arizona at the
modified art center and he was he didn't
have anym and I was like I got to go
home and I was a singer of the band you
know what I mean and and but we were all
[__] up
and it got worse and worse and uh I kept
using and I would work I worked at a
Coldstone creamy um I worked at lucadia
Pizzeria um I
uh like for the I I I was a DI hard
junkie slamming heroin and Coke but I
was like somewhat keeping it together um
we moved to Cardiff I don't know if you
ever been to Cardiff but it's like it's
like a four block area everyone had a
beach view mhm this was beautiful
beautifulu I was in my own place I was
doing good but I was using and
uh I got to the point too where I was
like I'm spending my whole life waiting
in parking lots for these drug dealers
to come it really bugged me I hated it
but I loved drugs like heroin the girl I
was dating at the time I told her if you
have you ever tried she asked me if she
asked me if I would date her and I said
I will and we could date and it could be
me and you but if you ever get me to try
and get me to stop using heroin or you
want to be more important to it all
deals like all bets off you'll never be
more important to me than
heroin and
um my friend Noah at the time moved to
Korea Town and a couple of my other
friends moved to Korea like in Korea
Town downtown LA and my friend Noah I
wanted to move back to LA cuz I was from
the valley but I went went to San Diego
and I always wanted to be the first of
our group to move back and I wanted to
bring our whole group here which we all
like our whole group is here now but
Noah was my best friend and he moved his
mom helped him and he moved to Korea
Town and he was he calls me on the phone
and he goes you got to check this out
this place is amazing I was like Korea
Town he's like no there's this place
called San Julian you can get her like
that I was like no way yeah you just
walk right up and I was like I'm going
to come over for a
weekend so I go over there for the
weekend he shows it to me we go down the
street he actually was too scared he
would peek down the street he like
looked down it and I was like [__] it
like if these guys are going down and
getting in I'm just going to walk down
the street St Julian is one of the
streets on skid yeah and it's like the
one like right on the side of the
midnight night Mission there's a park
there yeah San Julian park right we used
to go in that street though and I walked
down the street and then I for I think
they used to say like h h h or like
brown whatever they said for what they
had and I was like heroin and the guy
was like yeah and he's like with
balloons and I to me I was like no way
like I'm getting it now gave him the
money spits it out of his mouth gives me
the things they told I had to put in my
mouth in retrospect that unbelievable I
was I was a little scared like they they
were really scared but I immediately put
in my mouth out of his mouth walked down
the thing and I was like I got it let's
go back to the to your house and to me
the Simplicity of it was you walk down
the street and like a gumball machine
it's in your hand anyone else that was
from San Diego we'd wait in in parking
lots for 3 hours for one of these white
kids who's like like I'll be there in 10
minutes and we were like wasting our
lives in these parking lots and I had a
really good job I had a clothing company
called honeymoon clothing in San Diego I
had a record label it's called Phantoms
records we released some of the most
awesome albums for the local artists
that were there I was playing
music and I completely decided that
weekend that I wasn't going to go back
and that I was gonna be here on skid row
with Noah like as long as he'd have me
or you mean as long as as we could stay
there and and I just so I moved and I
had all the money that I saved up and I
was at the time I was like bartending at
located Pizzeria working at Coldstone
had this little clothing company I mean
I got up and left I had records I had
art I had Mark ala Prince I had Shephard
faery Prince like I was like deep into
the art and music scene I had this
insane record collection I had
Jordans and I got up and I just
left and um I was like enthralled with
skid
row and it was uh around that time
too I was like 21 yeah I was 21 cuz they
they just let me start bartending I
started as a buser no no no I started
out at L PR
folding boxes cuz that's kind of at the
time where I was with like using and I
think a lot of the guys thought I was
like a San Diego Stoner guy but quickly
I saw that the busers made left with
cash tips and I always needed drug so I
steep my game up and boom busing server
bartender like I quickly was able to
find how to make the money and where
they made it but
um Noah gets kicked out I go stay with
my aunt uh all my cousins and our
friends they were doing meth at the time
and none of them had tried heroin and I
to me heroin and cocaine together in a
syringe was the best thing in the world
and I thought everyone should know so
like I always to this day there's a lot
I have like a lot of I just thought it
was so great and I always thought that
like whatever it was that made me feel
unsafe like this made me feel safe and I
thought that I should share it with
everyone and quickly like I got all the
people around me strung out and
uh I went I since I was playing music a
little bit I went to music care sent me
to rehab and I went to cry help for the
first time and
um I don't know I I did like 30 days
there and I thought for sure when I left
there I I was like I for I 100% for sure
like have this I like got it beat I beat
an addiction and I left and it was like
a day or two and I was already like back
using um I don't know I was like in and
out of
jail
um I mean I would I would do anything
for it you know I uh
when I left cry help though the first
time I ended up at this house and I was
I was a it was a sober living and I was
like I was work I got a job on Melrose
working for this guy named
Cosmo and we were we were doing like
stylus work selling clothing and um I
don't know I really excelled at it
and we were like styling everyone it was
a
I don't know I mean it was like
every I was doing really really well and
one day he came in and I was just like
like blood dripping down my arm like in
the bathroom I'd been in there for an
hour and they were just like you're done
like you got to go and I was like doing
really good like I was like I uh I love
stylist work like I love Fabrics like
people are like what do you really like
to do I like I like to go feel Fabrics
like how they fall on the body and he
taught me everything about sales like
crazy like I I'm so good at sales now
like more like how to complement
someone's looks or all the pre things
that you do for sales and like how to
make the sale and I mean we would sell
like big like high money ticket like
there's like $5,000 dresses like $300
pants in there and uh he was very like
flamboyant like
he he was he was gay and he used to
always make the joke that like if he
could make one more sale he could get a
sex change he's like hey I'm Cosmo how
you doing like he was like he's not like
my mom but he like he I had this weird I
I got this like mother figure thing from
Cosmo he taught me so much about
everything I you know what I mean like
just how I've ever ever since then I
interacted people at sales um I've been
able to like create garments like I've
done dresses for people like with the
knowledge he's giving me like screen
printing
um and it was weird though too cuz he
was like he really it he
made this was like a long time ago so
this was he like blurred the line
between straight and
gay and he did it beautifully you know
what I mean it was like uh he kind of
like alleviated me of the
uh I don't know like what I thought gay
people were and and whatever I had
towards them like working with him like
it just it was fluid you know what I
mean like I lost my anything weird
towards it working with Cosmo I saw
everything like at our store people got
[__] in the back and hand jobs for
free clothes and got naked for you know
I mean if you get naked and show your
dick then you're going to get a free
pair of pants like um it was it was
crazy it's
Melrose and he comes from like the OG
Melrose um like I've hooked up with
girls in those dressing rooms and I mean
it was it was an amazing serious like
seriously amazing job and when I when he
fired me from
it it was really hard like uh so I had
gotten sober for a little while and I
got so high and like I would get so high
but then I'd come all the way back down
you know I mean I'm not talking about
like I got so high like I would do so
good like getting sober and I'd come
down and it'd be worse than it was
before and uh I started dating this girl
while we were in Melrose we moved into
like she had a condo and I moved into
it and uh so we we started using and
eventually we lost the
condo
um we I
had how did this happen so
I I went to jail in San Diego I forget
what I got arrested
for um I had to go to jail for a while
I'd already been I'd been to jail jail a
couple
times and I'm I don't know I I do it's
weird I can do good in jail cuz I'm kind
of like a shapes shifter from all the
things that I've been involved in and
being on skid row and different gang
members and these guys from 18th Street
just like the life you live of being on
Skid Row like it just whatever happens
happens
um I went to
jail and we lost the condo and I came
back and we moved to Kia town and uh the
girl that I was dating she would while I
was gone she started working as a
cocktail waitress at a strip club and
um but she's you know what I mean like
she did whatever she could to survive
and she actually like M like had a place
for me to come to after
jail um but I don't know if you ever
seen the The Hangover the Asian guy from
The Hangover
she had this like Asian guy that was
just a complete psycho but Rich As [__]
and I don't know what the exchange ever
was but like she would go see him for
like a day or two and then she'd come
back with tons of money and crack and
everything
and I don't even know if she was like
prostituting I met the guy I had gone
over to his place and he's just like the
craziest he'd have like guns taken apart
on his bed he'd be like naked in his
room like jacking off or something I
don't know what he would do like he'd
have you know plate of crack out and our
our life was just
like it was like my life was getting
more and more insane like I would just I
was always in a in something like that
and
somehow me and her and she's never been
like this but but we end up like
homeless and we're like on skid row and
we're like in a tent and we're
sleeping I remember we we we'd be in a
tent and we'd be moving it all around
and at this point I would jump on the
red line and I'd ride it as far to North
Hollywood I'd rack every single thing I
could razors whatever and then ride it
all the way back and then sell it to the
fence and uh and then she would
sometimes do whatever she did with this
guy you know what I mean and we lived in
a tent and
uh um we were like Skid Row that's the
bottom it was the bottom and and you
know even worse was like we lost the
tent and that's the bottom yeah and we
moved into we moved under the bridge
across the street from the Disney Music
Hall and under the bridge it was section
off right and each little guy had their
section and one section opened up which
was like a hot commodity to get but it
was the one where the rain gutter
drained
into so if it rained all the water came
into our
spot which it did a couple of times and
and we lived under that bridge and like
neither of
us you know what I mean like we're like
that kind of people and and
everything everything got darker and
darker you know what I mean and it was
it was so
much it was so much harder to like get
money when you can't take a
shower it was so much everything was so
hard you're so tired if you can't sleep
in a bed um and it' be it'd been like
months we're un you know we're
homeless and pretty much at this time I
was open to do anything and like I was
telling you ear earlier like whatever it
was that made money the quickest way I
was down and
um a couple of times like different
people approach me you know with like
the prostitution idea and I always just
saw the prostitution idea as like oh you
have to just like bend over somewhere
and get it and
uh and the first one the first time that
someone took me they took me to a
dentist in
Glendale and basically he's like you
know I thought I was just going to talk
they're like if you just come talk to
the guy he'll give you 20 bucks and I
was like great all I need is 20 bucks
you know what I mean like that'd be
awesome where do we go hold on I'm G
have the guy ubas uas over there we
might have even taken the bus I can't
remember I'm pretty sure Uber was around
and we go over there we sit in the
office this old guy comes out like super
big old guy and he's like yeah come into
my office and uh he's like here both of
you guys take off your clothes and I was
like all right is this how we get the
$20 like I take took my clothes off and
then he's like would you so would you
give him head and I was like you didn't
tell me we were doing this and he's like
the guy says to me well let him take a
shower but I wasn't like signed up for
this yet you know what I mean and I was
kind of like what the [__] is going on
and he didn't tell me enough about it
and the guy kind of got freaked out cuz
I had like no
clue you know and so he was like he
didn't want to do it and they sent me on
my way
um but he gave me 20 bucks and I was
like wait so this you could do this and
there's there's other ones so like
there's like a network of guys that that
they all actually know the same three
guys guys they like cycle through
between the doctor the
lawyer and the dentist and it's like
these guys that go and do this um I was
able to like find like in that Network
find guys that were one guy he would
just he'd have me come over and I would
lay in the bed at his place and he would
sit he would sit at the end of the bed
and not not do anything but he would sit
right by the bed not get on the bed and
if I wanted to do anything he said let
him know but he just wanted me to be
safe in the bed and I did that like a
bunch of times you know what I mean it
was it was like I literally went in this
nice house he would give me a shower let
me sleep in a bed uh the shitty part
about it is is my girlfriend would have
to just be fend for herself like in
Downtown LA and I'd be like in this nice
bed with this like you know he was kind
of fat like just very but very normal
looking guy super kind like brought me
into his office to show me hey I own
this whole building and this and like
you know what I mean and and he never
did anything crazy or weird so I was
like this is not that bad you know what
I mean like and other times it was like
I remember this one time the guy just
pulls
up so I was like over by Vermont and
Santa Monica he had like a white Jeep he
like pulls up he picks me up and then
he's like I just like he's like I'm
going to give you like 150 bucks if if I
could give you head and I was
like I had nothing dude I was homeless
living on a street it was just like run
it you know what I mean
like and I just did you know what I mean
like like that was like super shortlived
and I was so like I don't I don't know
if cuz you're so sick it's like anything
to like make me feel well you know
and
um yeah it just kept going
like those like little runs would last
for a while it's really crazy because at
a certain point of that I think the girl
that I was dating at the time she had
like moved in with the Asian guy pretty
much fulltime and I was like she'd come
down town and help me out but like no
more just like staying down there with
me she like pretty much I'm pretty sure
lived with that
guy and he had gotten another girl
too and uh yeah and that was around the
time that I was doing anything to
survive you know what I mean um I
remember this one day I was just done I
was like by myself sleeping under the
bridge and I walk down to the payone I
call my friend
uh from San Diego and he was like I
think he even said like stay right where
you're at I didn't have a cell phone
nothing say right where you're at I'm
gonna come pick you up and help you and
this is crazy cuz he picked me up and
helped me I went to meetings I stayed
sober he does like event industry stuff
um like he left me with his son who was
just born at the time and his wife at
the time and I kind of got myself I kind
of got my act together for the most
part and um I was at there's a barber
named kamacho and he used to he would
cut my hair for free and talk to me and
he knew I was getting sober and then I
really went through the ringer trying to
get
sober and uh I would go over to his
Barber Shop was at his house and he
would let me sit there he'd give me a
haircut I'd sit down and just like like
he'd get clients they'd come in and come
come in and go and um one of the guys
was like listen there's this new thing
it's called a ecigarette and these
things are going to blow up and I was
like really he's like yeah it's called
an Ego C Twist he's like this this
starter comes with two of them um an
E-liquid and they sell for this much and
I think they're around like 50 or $75
for the kit I'm like no way and he's
like yeah this is the new thing people
are going to quit smoking they're going
to do this and I was like well how can I
get some he's like actually I have a
garage full of them he's like if you
wait right here I'm going to go get some
I'm bring it back to you when you sell
them you pay me back this guy didn't
even know me but like the kamacho are
barber I don't if you ever been in a
barber shop you like link real quick
with people you know what I mean and so
he get some for me I sell them we get
more I sell them I get more I sell them
I tell my brother about it my brother's
always down he's he's a real estate guy
now
super smart like businessman um we he
comes in up on it and we buy more
together and sell them and then we're at
the uh Kobe swap meet in San Diego we
got a booth and we're selling them and
uh it just it kind of takes off for me
and for some reason I always go back to
LA and I made the decision to come back
to LA while all this was taken off uh
this is like the crazy it's such a weird
thing but there's a thing called a Cape
Cod wipe I don't know if you ever heard
of it it polishes
metal um so the original after the ego
SE twist came out they had mods there
were these metal mods brass copper
different metals and they would tarnish
and I was like dude what if we made a
package with this Cape Cod bought it
wholesale put two of them in here call
it mod shine this is like the logo from
it
um and we sell a mod shine package so we
repackaged Cape Cod buy it wholesale put
in this black myar bag make the freaking
logo look awesome everything and we did
and it
hit um like everybody wanted mod shine
it was like new The Vape industry was
the Wild Wild West you could make
anything and call it Vape related and it
was selling um I moved back to
LA and I I immediately started [__]
up I'd been sober and I made the
decision to get on methadone sober like
I wasn't going to kick I wasn't sick and
I got a job at this place called Vape
day and just like anything that I do I
pretty much took like I wore all the
hats there I ordered the wholesale the
distribution stuff I ran the social
social media like I did as much as I
possibly could over
there um and I was back on
methodone
and I called Sarah or the girl that I
was dating the one that was with the
Asian guy and I had talked her in a long
time and I was doing good and I was like
I'm back in
LA and she's like where you at I told
her she comes over so I'm doing really
well I'm just for some reason I decided
to get on methadone I'm running like a
bunch of parts of this company and um I
decided to get on methadone and when she
come she came with crack and she was
smoking crack like crazy at this point
and me too I'm like I love you I still
to this day it's like crack you know
what I mean I don't know what it is my
life is amazing but like you say crack
and I'm like that stuff is great and
like I my life is beyond amazing and do
doing that would be the dumbest thing
and uh she came over that day and she
brought crack syringes heroin everything
this guy decked her out nice purse um
brand new pipes you know what I mean
like we didn't used like that when it
was me and her downtown we had like a
small broken pipe that's like burning
our
lips and the Allure of it was just like
and she does not stop when she's using
she just smokes back to back to you know
I mean and I was like I'm doing really
good I just wanted to see you so you
could know that I'm doing good and and
maybe so you could like go like be mad
that you left me or whatever
happened and I
immediately she sits down it's like
three or four and she starts
smoking I start smoking she gets not she
doesn't ever get sick but she starts you
know she starts fixing I start fixing
we're smoking back to back and and
whatever time it was then it was the
next day and my assistant like walks in
at this vape shop that I'm working at
she was actually like the owner's
assistant but she'd like help me with a
lot of things and all the stuff was
there and I was high and my face was
picked and they were like you're
done
and I did like really well in The Vape
industry like but I was high I ended up
uh I ended up partnering with this other
lady opening a store on brand and Maple
and it was called the factory vape and
there's still reviews like on Yelp from
it and uh even this guy just messaged me
a couple days ago he's like you've came
so far from when you used to serve
people Vape without pants on cuz like I
was so high so I I thought it was a good
idea too to paint the vape store bright
pink like everyone remembers it that's
in Glendale we are right across the
street from Mercedes
I do the thing bright pink paint the
logo on the front the factory Vape
selling I mean I'm high out of my mind
at this point so every day I was
drinking vodka I was shooting heroin I
was smoking meth shooting Coke and I was
making really good money at the time I
had this Amazon account that was just
sell like you would it'd be printing
while you're sleeping cuz it would just
print as it made the sales like
and then every morning I wake up and
tear them and I'd put this one ipv3
smoking device into each thing slap the
label boom I'm done I just made you know
what I mean I'm doing all these drugs
and to wake up I never drank like this
and I feel so bad for alcoholics I used
to always talk [__] about them i' be
like I can't believe you're just an
alcoholic like get a real habit dude
alcohol is no joke so I I started
drinking like a gallon of vodka every
morning how I woke up is I'd wake up and
I'm like [__] blood puking I'm sick
if I fall asleep I get sick I get the
withdrawals but now I'm on [__]
alcohol I'd wake up I'd go in this
bathroom I'd be shaking and I didn't
know what to do I had to either stop the
shaking by drinking the vodka or I had
to shoot the dope to be well enough so
my eyes could see you know what I mean
it was one of the two I'm puking it's a
nightmare so I get the vodka in I shoot
the dope the cocaine or shoot the the
dope in the meth I'd get well and then I
would smoke I'd be drunk now though
because I'd have to get drunk as [__] to
stop shaking to like get this syringe
somewhere in me hence walking out with
no pants so anywhere I could find it
like now when I go to the doctor they do
right here one vein left on the bottom
of my foot and there's nowhere else like
I'd be so [__] if for some reason they
have to like resuscitate me but I'm like
shaking and then it stops and I'm kind
of well but now I'm drunk and I'm too
high on heroin so then I got to smoke
some meth then I get too methed out so I
would take some Xanax or I'd get a
what's the other one we had I can't
remember we had xan I'd always have
Xanax and something else and then I got
GHB I don't know why I started taking
GHB but to me it was like the magic
cocktail of the heroin the coke the
drinking too much meth aanx and GHB and
then I would go out and work and I was
[__] demolished and you would come to
this vape
store just like this kid said I might
not have had pants on you know what I
mean I'm standing behind the thing I'm
serving like Vape juice there's all
kinds of people in the back of The Vape
Shop like doing
drugs this girl that said her name was
baby girl and I believed her she had an
ID that said it was baby girl she'd be
back there
um dude like all that goes with the drug
things like you know transsexual
prostitutes in the back um like I
remember too this one time just like
this little Mexican guy jumped in my car
and I brought him back and he was like
like banging this this prostitute in my
office as we're open on the other side
like rabidly like behind her and I was
like opening the door to serve customers
and this guy's
like and I'm like shutting the door like
hey how can I help you people would come
into the vape store and they would be
like this is the [__] crazy so like
you'd come in the vape store and you're
like I want to serial killer Vape juice
and one gr of heroin and do you have any
Xanax and like the guys were sitting
right there and I'd be like yeah here
and I'd ring the card
through it was like dude and and and in
the moment I thought I was a genius I
was like this is the best way that
anyone could ever do this and like in
retrospect dude I had so and the money
was good the money was good The Vape
money was good this is pre them
switching the 21 over you know I mean
for smoking and this was pre them taxing
anything what year is this uh shoot it's
like n years ago now okay eight or nine
so nine years ago when I started I've
been sober six so like you know six and
a half 7 years ago is when I ended
that and dude we were doing like the
we were going to like Las Vegas to do
the trade shows and this and and and I
it was I was doing very well it made no
sense you were you were kind of a
functional addict I was I was very
functional I got like as I mean as high
as I was but like I would do the things
every day I would mop the thing as soon
as I got well front to back to the store
I'd like open everything up I'd wipe it
down and like from what Cosmo told me I
was ready to sell like when that door
opened and you needed something I was
selling it to you like you were not
walking out without buying
something mind you sometimes like I'd be
passed out on the front you'd have to
wake me up and um like I said the array
of characters in the back it was like
open
24/7 you know what I mean we I never
left I actually lived there so I was
like homeless in The Vape Shop cuz I
wouldn't leave um I got super
paranoid meth destroyed me like so the
LA one of the last things that happened
at that Vape Shop is uh so I thought
everyone was following me I'd stay
watching the cameras dude there's this
one officer Moyers who like I called him
he was a client he was like a vape
client but I called him and I'm like why
are they all outside watching
me he's like what are you talking about
I said they're they're all outside
watching me I was like do you are you
linked to the FBI can you talk to them
can you just tell them I'm a good guy
and it was just it was insane and so
what happened too though is I walked so
one of I thought they were following me
I don't know who it was I thought they
were I walked out of the store one day
and I looked and I passed like
BMW I think was on my side and I could
see them walking and every time that I
passed something there they were Mark I
jumped on buses that went this way got
off and then went back this way and then
I went to the LA River and I climbed so
like I don't know what they use them for
but there's these big concrete circles
right and they put them in under the
freeway or something and I climbed up
one and I was done like I was like
whoever's after me I'm jumping off this
thing they're not going to get me I'd
rather die the meth made you paranoid so
paranoid um um somehow these people got
me down but I thought that they were the
ones I trusted them to come down I
thought they were the ones and I started
running up into the street and the cops
came the paramedics I was trying to
fight them they handcuffed me I was
fighting everyone telling them go [__]
yourself you're not going to kill me I
remember this [__] it was crazy and then
they didn't arrest me I've been arrested
so many times I've been arrested I have
a strike I have a petty theft I have a
grand theft I have possession possession
possession um prop 36 all these things
they didn't arrest me and they put me in
a mental health
facility when I went in the mental
health
facility it was the first time that I
thought
maybe I am
crazy maybe I need
help
um maybe
there is something I could do about
this but they gave me a prescription of
squil uh prescription of
Wellbutrin and they sent me on my way
this was like the Pinnacle it was the
end I've been working at that vape shop
every day I thought they were after me
this guy I had this friend oh my God you
should have this guy this guy Cody would
take care of everything I did if I
dropped my drugs he would pick him up if
I dropped all my money he'd get it he
never once [__] me over he looked out
for me so hard um I couldn't go back to
the Vape Shop cuz they were there I
don't know who it was but they were
there and so basically we had to move
the drug dealing
business to a guy's house down the block
from The Vape shop where I like come out
and serve and then to my friend's house
and uh
it
was
dude they released me with the Cel and
everything now the guy Cody who's always
looked out for me this is this is his
daughter tattooed on my arm my
goddaughter
Dakota
um she's my cousin's daughter they were
together my cousin passed away actually
I don't they say it's not from drugs but
we've all in our family suffered from it
um Co Cody was like always there for me
and I was convinced at that point that
he was the one that was trying to get me
and I would like lose my [__] on him and
he was literally just trying to help me
and I was like you are the one like why
are you doing this I'd be crying Bing in
tears and after they let me out of that
mental health facility I went to his
house this one night and I was just
like like I need my drugs back and the
money and all stuff that was from the
register he gave it to me too he didn't
take any of it didn't he never did he
literally was like only looking out for
me and I was convinced that him the last
one that I trusted was the one cuz it
had to be him there was no one else and
this was all in my head and so I leave
his house that day he gave me the drugs
um I walked down Ventura now we're in
the valley I'm walking down Ventura I
get to the bowling alley and I was like
I'm done like I'm done with this life
and I took all the cak Quil I took all
the
Wellbutrin um I did all the drugs and I
walked down the street and at about
where the Urban Outfitter is is there
now I just remember looking up and just
spinning off and boom falling
back and like I told you since I had no
veins when I woke up this [__] [__]
was jamming needles into my foot trying
to bring me back like bring back to life
basically somewhere she could like there
was no veins there's no veins like
they're gone like all these veins behind
here they're all gone my feet she
couldn't find anything but I was losing
my [__] cuz she's jamming a needle into
the bottom of my foot and I don't know
if you could even imagine it but it's
they were trying in my palm of my hands
which I already did I used that but I
never even knew on the bottom of my foot
there was veins and they were jamming
needles in the bottom of my foot and I'm
losing it I'm like what the [__] is go
holy [__] what and I'm like someone's
holding me down I might have been
handcuffed I think to the bed I know I
couldn't move and I'm losing my [__] and
then they're like you know what just get
out they like discharge
me and they put me in the front and I'm
like I'm GNA [__] kill
myself like what the [__] like what is
going on and then I called the police I
called the police from the front of the
thing and they eventually put me back
and then they brought me to Hawthorne me
no hold on so that time they brought me
to BHS Behavioral Health Services it was
in North Hollywood so now this is the
second mental hospital I've been in they
5150ed me and I'm in there too and I'm
just
like why am I not dying like what like
what the hell is going on like I just
want to die you know what I mean like
I'm like pleading with God I remember
and this is kind of how I really started
to believe in him again but I'm like you
have to let me die this is too much like
I I can't keep doing this and um I'm in
there and this is the crazy we have such
an amazing mental health facilities in
the United States I'm in there nothing's
better like it was SE like 72 hours hit
and they gave me the same prescription
right back that I just tried to kill
myself
with and I left there and of course too
I call Cody again I'm like
listen hey I'm coming over you got give
me whatever I have left and I don't even
know if I had anything coming left at
the time and but he knew he knew I was
uh out of it um I thought I had this
tracking device in the back back of my
thigh which there's a scar
from and that night I went over there to
try and pick it
out and um and I'm dripping blood dude
like I'm taking a step like I put pants
on cuz he's like you got to go and each
thing is like dripping blood onto the
ground and um he gave me some drugs
and I left and I just did what I had and
then the next day I ended up somehow
over on Vermont and Santa Monica and
over on Vermont and Santa Monica was
this sober living I'd always gone in and
out of and I was high as [__]
dirty like you know no shower I'm like
out of these mental health facilities
like back to back trying to commit
suicide and um I go up to the guy who
helped me at the sober living and I was
like I need to come in this is sober
living it's not a treatment it's it's
not a
detox like no you cannot come in like
you're dirty you smell you're like on
drugs right now and I just took it
like like
uh this is the last stop on the bus he's
not even taking me back just in my mind
and they won't stop following me no
matter what I
do so I remember we're at Vermont Santa
Monica
and I'm like I like get high and walk
I'll walk from Burbank to Downtown LA so
I get on ver ver Sam the red line I take
it all these different places to like
the Gold
Line and then I sit there and I look and
I'm like I should jump in front of the
Gold
Line I have to do
this and then my head thinks well what
if you don't die and you're paraplegic
and then this head that you have is
stuck inside of a a wheel wheelchair and
you can't ever be fine again so I didn't
do it rode it back to Downtown LA there
was this one bridge that I was like I
could jump off this bridge and I know
I'll die but I got scared
again I take it back over there and I
was like I got to ask him again to let
me in the sober living but it just
didn't work like that I I think I had a
couple dollars left so I bought like a
ice or something and boom I did the same
thing I did like the last of the drugs I
had took the cakil took the Wellbutrin
like down the freaking uh butt ice and I
was sitting right next to a pay phone I
just remember looking up and the pay
phone was there and boom the next time I
woke up was in Hawthorne
Medical dude it was like so crazy
there's like in ha medical I made
friends with this like skin head guy and
then this girl and I don't know what was
going on
but it was like I I couldn't die and I I
I don't know like how many people you've
ever interviewed or my game plan always
was to kill myself that was going to be
the way out that's how it was going to
end if it ever got too bad I'm G to die
like I I'll kill myself like it has to
be that way and I always just assumed
it'd be an overdose and it'd be
intentional and um so like I go to hawor
medical and now dying is off the table
and I'm now I'm like I'm crazy I'm like
in here with crazy people and I need
help like I need to get well like what
is going to help me you know what I mean
and
uh so I I finished like the hold that
they had at hawthor Medical and uh I
remember I called my same friend that
picked me up from the side of the road
don't leave by the the the phone I
called him again and no one else would
take my phone calls and these the people
were literally since the suicide
attempts were so close they kept on
talking about conservatorship you know
what I mean and it was like you kind of
have to have someone to like back you up
to not be on like a family member or
someone has to say like no like we're we
want to help him and nobody my brother
wouldn't take the calls my dad like
everyone's done with me and my friend
takes the call and he says listen if you
have a place to go I'm going to pick you
up but I'm going to drop you right off
at the place and that's it so I call a
bunch of places and I call Salvation
Army in San Diego and they said that
they would take me and um I get over
there and this is the craziest thing I
didn't say one word I walk in the door
with my staff and they and they said we
don't take dual diagnosis clients
I didn't even say that I I did because I
had the medication that I'm supposed to
take as prescribed but they looked at me
and said
that and then I was like yeah I do have
medication blah blah and so they don't
let me
come the Salvation Army and Pasadena
did and uh so I had to get you know I
mean like they highly suggest to if my
friend picked me up that they let the
medication stabilize me before I start
talking about the people and I you know
I wouldn't sleep and they were out to
get me and um so he just he he's like I
told you one place and I was like yeah
I'm not going to put you through this
again this you know what I mean like and
I called my aunt and I was like the
Salvation Army in pasadia said they'll
take
me um I got to like I have to get over
there so I go to her house um salvation
arm she doesn't want me to spend the
night so
I like
basically go to her house
and um I I like sleep outside the
Salvation Army 5:00 a.m. they wake up at
7:00 they take me I go in the Salvation
Army the Salvation Army you have to tuck
in your shirt you have to butt in your
shirt you wear a belt you're working
like 12 hours a day mind you I'm like a
junkie who's never worked a day in my
life this was the hardest thing in the
world you have to make your bed with
with like a like a crease in the
corner none of this made sense to me um
at all but I really didn't want what I
had and I knew that if I didn't do this
I might go back and suicide is not going
to work and uh the crazy thing about it
was I actually got
into see it's like I got into the church
like I liked being in the room and
people were happy and they were singing
and uh as much of the things that I
didn't like about
it I was like I want to not have my life
back that it was and I did the things uh
I I I stood in the front and I sang the
songs and I like that kind of Serotonin
boost or something you know what I mean
that I got
and and uh it was really hard I was on
like the the weekends I had to clean
extra cuz I couldn't keep my shirt
tucked in or I didn't wake up on time
and every weekend I had to do extra just
to stay there
and one day I guess I looked at someone
like I wanted to fight them and they
kicked me out I mean I was so bad at
being a Salvation Army client it wasn't
even funny so I was walking back and one
more time I was like sober though I got
like 90 days mind you I've never gotten
like this much sobriety ever in my
life um and I'm walking back I they kick
me out I have my bag of stuff and I'm
walking back to go to Cody's house so
maybe this will be the end of you know
what I mean I'm walking back in the
park the cops come and I see them coming
around and then they're just like BR
conell like put your stuff and I'm like
what the [__] dude so from selling drugs
and all the thing I was doing at The
Vape Shop there's a warn out for my
arrest and my partner on The Vape Shop
actually said that I robbed the store
that when I left that I took everything
and robbed the store which there is some
truth to that and I ended up pleading
like a no contest but I didn't take it
like like in a robbing way I just like
took the stuff that I thought was mine
when I left the
store but she did like an insurance
claim and got all this money and the
store was I mean obviously at the end of
the day it was like a big loss so I was
in jail and I was sober and I wanted to
you I kind of wanted to stay sober and I
was really I was really big when I went
in there and uh like you know I have
like bleached hair right now I had H at
Salvation Army they like make you get a
haircut like this but I had hair like
this like stuck to my face and like and
then I had the bleach but it really grew
out so when they cut my hair at
Salvation Army I had these like bleach
tips and so when I got arrested I had
the Leach tips and when I went into the
jail the first name that they gave me
was Chaz
Bono which is like sunny and shar's male
or female to male
son and I was super overweight you know
I mean like uh and I don't know I
started working out like I got into it
um I wanted to stay
sober and uh we I fought the case I
ended up taking a sentence that's like a
godsent because I'd never heard of this
but 16 with half in a split and I got
out the week of
um Christmas it might have been like two
or three days before Christmas
and I'm like still [__] out of my
mind and now I'd been in so I was in
Salvation Army for almost 4 months and
then I was in at LA County jail for like
4 months and still out of my mind full
flight from reality I get out it's
around Christmas I go to my aunt's house
and I didn't do the steps or anything
yet but I was like I'm going to make
amends I'm going to go over and I'm
going to clean everything and this and
help them and clean and and they were
just like what the [__] it's like
someone would like set something out be
like wiping down under it and I was like
still in like after all that time like a
crazy still meth
psychosis and Christmas happens and
everybody gives me someone gave me like
a socks someone gave me some shirts
someone gave me you know some toothpaste
and this and then my brother walks in
with a duffel bag and he's like where
are you going to go and I was like I'll
just stay an Cathleen and they're like
no like you're not staying here and I
was
like well then you got to take me to
Skid Row cuz where else would you stay
assuming that my brother wouldn't take
me to Skid Row and we get in the car he
puts a duel bag in the back he pulls up
to the Midnight Mission and boom he
drops me off on the side of the road now
I've never been on Skid Row unless I'm
like completely obliterated out of my
mind and that's why earlier when you're
asking me about the mission so I didn't
even know you could sleep in those
missions I always just slept on the side
of the street under the bridge in the
tent in the courtyard for the Midnight
Mission I didn't even know you could
sleep in the missions
so the first night I just go and ask
everyone like hey where do you sleep
around here if like you don't have where
to stay and they're like oh just line up
on S Pedro right there at 7 and then
they'll let you
in um so I lined up that night at 7 kind
of like loitered around that day but
like here's the crazy thing like I
didn't use and this was
like Monumental for
me and I didn't use and I lined up at
the thing at 7:00 I think at like8 8:30
or 9 they let us in they gave me aable
mat and a a blanket and I put it down so
tired just like loitering and skid roll
there I lay down I fall asleep I wake up
the mat's deflated to the ground and
there's a lot of mental health in in
there so someone also was cold so they
took my
blanket and um and then I wake up and
they're like hey who it's 4:30 who wants
to take showers I like like oh I should
take a shower so I could like figure
this out like I don't know how long I'm
going to be down here so I go into the
shower it's like a room it's like like I
don't know if if right where this you
know like right in between this black
thing there's like six shower spets and
then everyone just goes in and you
shower and it's not even
warm and like I said the mental health
situation over there so I'm like under a
get showering and someone just bumps
into me right from behind to go to the
shower and I'm like
dude like what you know what do I do
finish showering get up go in there sit
down eat kind of start talking to people
met some people that are like from
Russia their family moved here they're
like yeah our whole family moved and
we're on gr and food stamps and we're
just waiting to save enough to get a
place and I didn't have anyone at the
time and uh I went up to like share on
Fifth M Broadway it was like where they
had meetings and stuff and I kind of you
know started going to meetings getting
sober I stood outside the U-Haul with
these guys and I don't speak Spanish so
I stood out the U-Haul for days on end
to try and like make some money and
nobody picked me um I uh ended up moving
suits out of the back of a car into a
warehouse for like a couple hundred
dollar I got my
R and I moved into a sober living um in
like
Aza and I did that for a while got my
job back on
Melrose working with Cosmo and I really
excelled I started making people like
custom dresses
custom um like glasses all this stuff
doing really well on Melrose and kind of
just like you know from the U-Haul to
moving those things in to Melrose saving
enough money to actually move back into
that sober living that I was telling you
where the guy just told me to kick rocks
and I got started there and then my
friend Jacob who would still take my
phone calls was like oh [__] he's doing
better and he works Coachella stage
coach
EDC and I would always vicariously watch
what he is doing on the internet wishing
that I could like work on one of those
stages and he ended up basically
like calling me and he's like hey do you
want to work the Coachella and I was
like yeah they paid for the hotel it's
like breakfast lunch and dinner they
give you like the clothes you wear and
it was more it paid more for working
every day that whole month than like I'd
made in a long time or legally at all
ever probably and um it was weird too
cuz
my
my fiance
now um we've been friends since we were
13 she's actually like the first crush
that I ever had um I I lived on this I
lived like right the street from our
school Oak Crest and then her friend
lived by me and they would ride their
longboards and I was obsessed with her
like completely obsessed with her she I
sometimes too I think back and I'm like
I started using because of how you know
I mean like I remember how uncomfortable
I felt when she didn't want to be with
me when we were
younger but uh she saw me like working
stage coach and Coachella and and I was
doing this stylus work and uh this
lady um her name is Liz she did like
Pirates of the Caribbean she was Nicole
Kidman's assistant and she was like hey
my daughter wants to have her birthday
here cuz she met you and you styled her
and she wants her birthday party to be
here her aunt is or I think she said
aunt or godmother is Nicole Kidman and
she could pay for everything if you guys
could let her do it and I was like oh
yeah for sure talk to Cosmo he's like
yeah we're down we'll shut down the
store for them they could try on
everything as long as someone buys
something so then I tell Chelsea I'm
like hey do you want to come work with
uh you know this lady's Nicole Kidman's
goddaughter so we work together on that
thing um kind of like started talking
again and uh I'm back like on Melrose
working Coachella stage coach um I
started going to meetings I literally I
mean I'm like sober now at that time I
was sober like over a year my life is
like dramatically changed
um I uh I know this is like he's not
he's not like the I don't know how this
will be perceived to people that see it
but um I said I was going to I said I
want to work with Kanye West and you
mind you I was like mes psychosis guy so
when I said that a lot of people were
like that's really crazy
actually uh the Nicole Kidman people
thought I was lying when we did the work
thing cuz it was so out of whack
and um I stayed working production and I
ended up actually working on the kidse
ghost which is Kanye West and kid Cy
their collab I worked on the stage when
they played in the a bulletproof box
that they raised a bunch of stage and
actually Chelsea was there that night my
fiance um she says that our son was
conceived that night after the
show and it was like this big thing that
I was like I'm going to you know I told
people that and all these times we I'd
worked on these events and it was right
next to him where he was he worked he
did that Sunday service coella and that
was one of the days I had off and then
yeah so I worked at camp fogna on his
stage and then it was just like one of
many though not not any like real
attachment to it and I ended up going to
this company called Vox and they
actually did the Jesus's King record
release and I was like one of the six
people from our company at Vox that did
the Jesus king record release it was
like a thing you could come in walk
through listen to the album and uh yeah
I mean it is super crazy you you've
lived quite a life how old are
you 39 39 yeah you look great for 39
really yeah